wir sind im stadtzentrum von nablus im
von israel besetzten westjordanland nach
dem langen strikten lockdown hat hier
die palästinensische führung gerade die
notstandsgesetze wegen corona zum
dritten mal verlängert die strenge
ausgangssperre ist zwar aufgehoben
doch es gelten versammlungsverbote
abstandsgebot und mund nasenschutz
pflicht überall in der stadt hängen
diese plakate auf denen steht ihre
sicherheit ist wichtiger als ein
händeschütteln
doch die meisten halten sich nicht
wirklich daran
umgerechnet 25 euro strafe stehen auf
die verletzung der masten pflicht doch
polizei und ordnungsamt sehen untätig zu
die meisten tragen selbst keine maske
wär ich weiß ich bin eigentlich dazu
verpflichtet aber ich habe sie im büro
vergessen eine strafe zu verhängen
erklärt uns der beamte weiter sei
angesichts der schlechten
wirtschaftlichen lage unmenschlich die
leute hier hätten doch eh kein geld vor
einer woche sah das noch ganz anders aus
zum teil mit gewalt haben da die
palästinensischen sicherheitskräfte die
einhaltung der regeln umgesetzt so wie
hier in hebron schon vor corona ging es
den palästinensern wirtschaftlich
schlecht der lock down hat die lage
nochmals verschärft und das wolle man
sich nicht mehr bieten lassen erzählen
uns viele hier in der altstadt von
nablus
zudem kursieren immer mehr
verschwörungstheorien
hier gibt es doch gar kein corona und
wenn tut es uns nichts dieses corona ist
doch eine erfindung der medien
am anfang haben alle masken getragen
weil alle angst hatten aber da nichts
passiert ist alles irgendwie normal ist
interessiert es keinen mehr
vorsicht lassen nur wenige noch walten
klar geld ist wichtig aber mir ist meine
gesundheit wichtiger allerhand bern ist
der einzige laden besitzer der die
kunden noch nicht wieder dicht gedrängt
in seinen shop lässt die leute kommen
jetzt wieder alle raus ich hätte sonst
vielleicht zwanzig bis dreißig
gleichzeitig im laden da haben wir
beschlossen dass sie einfach draußen
bleiben müssen abstand halten
wie überall auf der welt wo maßnahmen
gegen das virus ergriffen wurden haben
auch im westjordanland viele menschen
ihren job verloren die arbeitslosenquote
von rund 26 prozent sei laut behörden
stark gestiegen
genaue zahlen aber habe man noch nicht
arbeitslosengeld gibt es nicht aber ein
paar unternehmen die in der not
erfinderisch wurden wie diese rucksack
und taschen fabrik und das ist das neue
krisen produkt schutzanzüge für
medizinisches personal und
sicherheitskräfte nehmen sie nur fünf
tage standen die nähmaschinen stillt bis
die neue produktion an die niemand
musste hier entlassen werden
am anfang haben wir 500 stück am tag
produziert nun 800 wir arbeiten sogar in
zwei schichten so groß ist die nachfrage
damit hätten wir gar nicht gerechnet
an diesem tag fertigen sie die
bestellung für die rettungskräfte und
sanitäter vom roten halbmond das
material für die anzüge kommt aus
deutschland das fertige produkt liefern
die palästinenser auch an israel in der
krise in der korona krise scheint die
politik sich zu wandeln neue dinge sind
möglich auch im abgeriegelten
gazastreifen ist hilfe zur selbsthilfe
angesagt hier sind sogar bis zu 75
prozent der menschen ohne festen job
in dieser fabrik wurde bis vor kurzem
noch kleidung genäht jetzt nennen sie in
ihrer verzweiflung schutzmasken für
ärzte und bevölkerung und auch hier hat
die herrschende hamas strenge
schutzmaßnahmen angeordnet denn schon
ohne corona pandemie gilt laut uno der
gazastreifen seit diesem jahr als nicht
mehr bewohnbar 13 jahre
wirtschaftsblockade drei kriege mit
israel überbevölkert zugemüllt ohne
ausreichend sauberes trinkwasser und
strom wenn das virus uns trifft können
wir die toten hier vermutlich nicht mehr
zählen
in gaza gibt es gerade mal 70
intensivbetten für zwei millionen
menschen in rafah im süden des
gazastreifens wird vorsichtshalber eine
quarantäne station aufgebaut
bis zu 1000 corona patienten hätten hier
platz wir brauchen unterstützung von
außen uns fehlen medikamente masken
intensivmedizinische geräte eigentlich
alles immerhin scheint hier die lage was
die infektionszahlen angeht bislang im
griff offiziell starben zwei menschen
durch das virus
ortswechsel wir sind in der altstadt von
jerusalem im arabischen ostteil der
heiligen stadt hier ist die verzweiflung
besonders groß keine bilder keine
touristen das entzieht den meisten
menschen hier in jerusalems altstadt die
existenzgrundlage zudem fühlen sich
viele palästinenser hier in
ost-jerusalem schlecht informiert sie
kennen die maßnahmen der regierung nicht
richtig und so macht sich manch einer
ein eigenes rezept gegen das virus so
wie diese männer hier
sie treffen sich zum kaffee so wie sie
es gewohnt sind und doch ist alles
anders
ich google jetzt immer mit zitrone salz
und essig das ist ein guter schutz so
lehr habe ich die altstadt nie erlebt
höchstens in der ersten intifada oder im
sechstagekrieg 67 ich habe schon angst
vor diesem neuen virus aber ich gucke
leben und bin vorsichtig nur der
konflikt um die heilige stadt plötzlich
kein thema in den straßen
das virus macht beide seiten verwundbar
alle die araber die juden die christen
der ganzen welt alle sind schwach und
verwundbar geworden auch die könige die
präsidentin alle normalen menschen sind
gleich schwach bislang scheint es als
seien die rund 5 millionen palästinenser
gesundheitlich gesehen bislang recht
glimpflich durch die pandemie gekommen
knapp 600 menschen sind positiv getestet
worden
doch es werden eben auch nicht
flächendeckend tests durchgeführt
wir fahren ins berater flüchtlingslager
in der nähe von nablus nur eins der
vielen dicht besiedelten
flüchtlingslager im westjordanland
hier ist die situation besonders
angespannt
hier im flüchtlingslager gibt es viel
mist informationen über das virus und
die bedrohung insgesamt wird er
ignoriert beziehungsweise klein geredet
denn hier sind die alltagsprobleme für
die menschen ohnehin groß genug
die schulen sind geschlossen
homeschooling findet in valletta nicht
statt
der druck sei enorm erzählt uns um alle
hier hat keine arbeit
man kann sich nicht frei bewegen die
kinder haben keine schule
das ist schon sehr schwierig eine
arztpraxis oder gar ein krankenhaus gibt
es hier nicht und die behörden kommen
nur ungern in das lager zu viel gewalt
potenzial
deshalb haben diese jungen
krankenpfleger nun in eigenregie eine
art anlaufstelle für mögliche patienten
eingerichtet
corona tests durchführen können sie
nicht testkits seien bestellt aber
bislang nicht angekommen
wir schreiben die namen und die
ausweisnummern von möglichen infizierten
auf dann rufen wir einen krankenwagen
bislang habe es zwar keine corona fälle
hier gegeben
aber ja sein hofft dass die menschen die
gefahr die von dem virus aus geht weiter
ernst nehmen es ist ramadan und die
moscheen sind geschlossen
wir haben corona in die moschee gesperrt
rufen sie uns hier scherzhaft zu
die meisten haben sich damit abgefunden
woanders bieten zu müssen
doch ramadan das bedeutet mehr als
fasten und beten das bedeutet auch
beisammensein in groß familie und
gemeinschaft
wir sind bei den baader nees eingeladen
die letzten vorbereitungen für das
fastenbrechen werden gemeinsam erledigt
wir sind durch corona alle zu hause die
ganze zeit es ist wie im bienenstock
einer matte vorspeise die anderen das
hauptgericht
das hat uns auch näher zusammengebracht
ich hoffe das bleibt so nur ohne krone
es sind wirklich auch viele schöne
momente
ich hatte befürchtet wir streiten uns
aber es scheint als seien wie eine nette
familie die balance halten sich strikt
an die regeln
wir sind die ersten besucher sonst
sitzen nur die eltern und kinder am
tisch
es wäre eigentlich auch üblich mal mit
bis zu 100 leuten gemeinsam zu speisen
erzählen sie uns nach dem fastenbrechen
würden sie eigentlich noch einmal in die
stadt gehen kaffee trinken die
atmosphäre genießen
doch die kaffeehäuser sind noch
geschlossen und ab sonnenuntergang
müssen alle geschäfte zu sein
fliegende händler zu hause am abend
herrscht hier eine strenge
ausgangssperre die polizei kontrolliert
sogar jedes auto das durch die stadt
fährt denn auf der straße soll
eigentlich hier niemand mehr sein
dieses auto dreht mit genehmigung in der
gesamten stadt stunden lang seine runden
es versprüht desinfektionsmittel ein
neues ritual am abend auf das alle hier
gut verzichten könnte
[Musik]